[Music]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream
our thirty seven seventh sorry
i almost jumped the gun and said it was
our 38th our 37th i am here with dr
heather hein
and the cat in the background and oh
crap oh no it's one of ours i don't
think it's too dangerous yeah
um that's fairfax drinking from the sink
yes i think he might be drinking the
remnants of my coffee sure
all right um so i think we're gonna
start off
today with an announcement about unity
2020.
um things are moving into high gear
folks we are opening our nominations
for candidates as of today
we are going to give you a link that you
can go to
there is no reason you need to go to it
right now the nomination process will
remain
open for about eight days
and there is no priority given to early
nominations so you have plenty of time
to go there and tell us who you who you
want to nominate
we are getting uh we are going to accept
two
nominations per person you don't have to
give us two but if you want to nominate
two people
maybe even a a ticket that you think
would be good you can go to the
website and you can tell us who they
might be
you will be able to tell us whether you
think that they
are on the left or the right though
those are just simply indications of
your
perspective those are not binding
categories
uh we will soon that is to say in the
early part of this upcoming week we will
open
a platform on which we will be able to
uh have debate over the merits of
various
nominees that have been advanced
we will go through the list to make sure
that candidates match
all of the characteristics that are
required
and ultimately we are working towards
a narrowing of the field to all of the
viable candidates and we will hold
a vote likely with ranked choice voting
since we are strong supporters
of that mechanism and have candidates
by the beginning of september
uh let's see anything else that we need
to say yes so the nominations will
remain
open until the 16th the comment uh the
comment and debate period will begin
early this week
primary voting will be by the end of
august
and we should have a unity ticket by the
first week in september
to begin our draft process and you're
going to post a link you're going to
mention the link at the end of this
first
hour of our episode yes i tell you what
why don't we
tell them the link now you don't have to
go to it we will remind you of the
the url at the end it is archer you can
show the page it's articlesofunity.org
nominate that's the place you can go and
it will ask you some
questions and then you can give us your
nominations so we look forward to this
process it's going to be very exciting
um buckle your seat belts
all right all right so there are a
number of things we wanted to talk about
today besides that
um one of the things is that you wanted
to explain why you predicted that biden
would not make the nomination
of democrats we also have some stuff to
talk about with regard to kovid
sunlight compelled speech a number of
other issues
emerging but do you want to start with
uh discussing your prediction
that the democrats would drop biden as
their candidate yes
and i can tell you right now if you are
thinking about making such an
unlikely prediction be prepared for a
lot of pushback of people who feel very
clever for telling you that the thing
that is so
unlikely to happen is very unlikely to
happen which i already knew
um but in any case i what i wanted to
get at is the fact that we
are facing an unprecedented situation
where i believe both major party
candidates are showing
significant signs of mental decline
looks like uh the standard kinds of
confusion that old people sometimes face
but i don't believe we have a precedent
for
a major party candidate suffering
decline that appears to compromise them
with respect to the very role for which
they have been
nominated at least not in such an
extreme form
and so we are seeing lots of uh
hints of you know we saw a trial balloon
floated in the new york times about
possibly
getting rid of the debates um and
we have seen that joe biden will not be
accepting the nomination in person
and i would say maybe there are examples
i'm unaware of but i cannot
recall the last um
the last incident in which joe biden has
shown up
on a live interview or in person to
deliver a speech where there was not
a major gaffe that appeared to be the
result of
cognitive decline now the gop has
released a
uh a campaign ad that
uh of course it will be the least
generous interpretation possible but
they released a campaign ad that
compares
joe biden of 2008 with joe biden 2020
and it does appear quite a stark
comparison so
what i'm getting at is this i believe
there is awareness
inside the democratic party that joe
biden
cannot be president and probably cannot
win
the presidency if he is forced to go
through something like a debate that
would reveal the extent
of his mental decline and whatever plan
they seem to have
for keeping him out of the public eye
except in very scripted
circumstances does not appear to be
working we have one gaffe
after the other and so there is a
question about what
makes sense for them to do and of course
joe biden bowing out of the race which
would probably be very much i should say
i take no pleasure
in pointing out the man's mental decline
as much as i'm not a fan of him
politically
it's very sad to see somebody in the
public eye uh who
is just incapable of even looking out
for himself
he deserves a better final act yeah i
mean i
i don't want to say deserves but i would
just say there's no i think i think
really you know he's no one is no one is
suggesting that the man is evil
i think every honorable human being
deserves an honorable final act and this
isn't
this isn't that this isn't that but in
any case
we have a different problem our problem
is not joe biden's
well-being or his uh emotional state our
problem is how to get the country
governed so that we can be safe and move
in the right direction and obviously
um that's not occurring here so i would
just point out one thing
is that those of us who are focused on
the fact that we have
what appears to be an incompetent person
running on a major party
ticket take a lot of flack for not
getting in line because
people who tell us this are laser
focused on getting trump out of office
that's the only thing that they can see
and i would just point out that as with
2016
the only interpretation here is that the
fact that we have a candidate who does
not appear
capable of winning by virtue of his
obvious
competence to do the job and a
desirability to be in the office
that's the fault of the democratic party
now you can blame it on
democratic voters who nominated somebody
who is incompetent or you can blame it
on the dnc and the skullduggery that
obviously unfolds around the primaries
but one way or the other
in an era where we are told that donald
trump is an existential threat
and that he absolutely must be
eliminated from office at all costs you
would expect the democratic party
to have rallied around somebody who was
absolutely unimpeachable and absolutely
clearly competent
so that there would be no reason
whatsoever that any rational person
could vote against them instead they
have delivered us
a situation in which we have massive
cognitive dissonance where people
have to put aside the obvious evidence
of his decline
in order to vote for him this is exactly
the opposite of what a patriotic party
would have done and so as this becomes
unavoidable and we've had people
discussing this for
months we've had crystal ball
and uh sauger and jetty talking about it
david packard has talked about it
caitlyn johnstone has talked about it
many people have been aware
of this pattern and have talked about
the obvious implications that it has so
this is not
a new problem this is something the
democratic party has been trying to
manage
and the reason for my prediction is that
i believe
the rate of decline is severe enough
that it is almost impossible to imagine
him
um winning and
finishing out a four-year term much less
being re-elected
and back in december he floated the idea
that maybe he wasn't going to run he has
not pledged not to run as far as i
understand
but he floated the idea to insiders that
he would be a one-term
president so already there's awareness
that a two-term biden presidency is
implausible
and then i as i said i don't think he's
very likely to make it four years
how likely is he to make it two years is
the plan for him to be elected and step
down
immediately might the plan be for him to
be nominated and then step down giving
the dnc the ability effectively to
choose
his replacement so all of these things
are in play so my prediction
while i agree it's pretty unlikely in
light of the
in light of the way things have played
out in the primary
is predicated on the fact that i believe
there is a behind behind-the-scenes
discussion going on on how to manage
this obvious crisis that has emerged
so that we don't have the situation of
biden
and trump in a debate where biden's
obvious decline becomes unavoidable
and people vote for trump simply because
he seems to be the more competent of the
two
so how are they going to manage that if
they can't shut down the idea of debates
i believe something is going to happen
in advance of that
that will change the
narrative dramatically hence my
prediction so
is it really likely to happen i can't
say it'll be
pretty fascinating if it does but if it
doesn't happen i would say there's also
a period of time
after the nomination and before the
election in which it could happen which
might be the most logical time
for a swap to take place and then
there's the possibility of an election
i it's hard for me to imagine him being
elected if he has to
spend time in public
campaigning because gaffe after gaffe
will emerge but let's say he was elected
will he step down in the first year
all of these things are possible what
you think is the most likely
is an open question i've told you i
think actually there's a
pretty good chance he doesn't make it to
nomination
well this is going to seem like a uh a
sharp turn from what you were just
talking about but you prompted me to
think with your
opener there that people who think
they're clever for telling me this is an
unlikely
uh prediction um are not telling me
anything i don't know
this reminded me um in episode 36 q a we
got a super chat question
asking if we would post uh one of the
covenants that we had used
that were the formal agreement between
faculty
and our students as to what we expected
of of them and what we would be
offering to them and i as
i said i would i posted on medium the
covenant that we used in our 2015-16
full-year program that included 11 weeks
in ecuador in the middle evolution and
ecology across
latitudes this was the covenant for just
the first quarter
fall quarter with 50 students we did a
couple of domestic field trips but it
did not include
you know we had it we had separate
documents um outlying the expectations
etc for study abroad
um but what you said about hypotheses
um being unlikely making them
stronger hypotheses is actually built
into this covenant so i thought maybe i
would just read a couple
a couple of items from this covenant
that that i did post as as i promised to
zach if you would show this is on medium
for people to find if they want this
incidentally is a picture that you brett
took
of several of our students at ingapurka
which is
uh the northernmost site at the
northernmost
part of the incan range uh in ecuador
the inca were only in ecuador for about
80 years before the spaniards arrived
but interestingly at ingoparka this is
completely an aside but at ingoparka the
incans
were not just in charge they came they
tried to conquer they failed to conquer
and they ended up in negotiation with
the kanyari a royal wedding ensued and
the kanyari
and the inca were in sort of uneasy
peace at this at the city state in
ingoparka and this is some of our
students there on the day trip that we
took there from
cuenca uh so there's there's a lot here
but the rules are these i'm going to
read the first six the
bottom of which ends with a discussion
of hypothesis one failure is to be
expected
it is an inherent part of success
understand its meaning but don't dwell
on it more than is useful
we your faculty respect failure as it
reveals an honest risky attempt to try
something new
what is not respectable is failing to
fail or failing to succeed
because you did not make any attempt at
all
two you are not in competition with each
other everyone can succeed
everyone can fail some can succeed while
others fail but no one needs to fail for
others to succeed
remember this is not instructions for
life often in life we are in competition
with one another
but students in our classrooms were
explicitly not there was no grading on
the curve there was no we need to have x
number of people getting
c's or below and y number of people
getting a's there was none of that which
is
you know those those sorts of models
those educational models grading on the
curve and such
are quite dishonorable because they
assume that the sort of the bell curve
expectation of student uh ability upon
entering the classroom
is exactly the same shape upon leaving
the classroom and maybe it shifted a
little bit to the right but the curve
itself hasn't changed and we would hope
to move that into something that didn't
look like a bell curve such that more
and more people were
at the top end of the spectrum with
regard to ability and understanding
so i would point out that there are you
think you indicated this there are
things for which you do want a
competitive model
absolutely but the idea that schooling
is one of them is more or less
predicated on the idea that nothing of
substance will happen there
in other words that um you know a bell
curve makes sense
if you are not in a positive sum
environment it's an environment
where actually the quality of what
emerges in terms of
insight is adjusted by how people view
each other
a willingness to play an assist
you know in an intellectual discussion
for example
that has to be incentivized or what the
sum total the emergent capacity of the
entire room full of people
is reduced if they view each other as
competitors rather than as partners
exactly three in our covenant between
our students and
us in our year-long program in 2015-16
3. treat those around you with respect
be candid when something needs to be
said
or when someone needs to be defended be
honorable and honor others
four apologize for harm you have caused
accept earnest apologies from others
five everyone has the right to take back
things they no longer believe or that
not properly represent their beliefs
when they originally spoke
speak knowing that you can change or
retract what you have said and listen to
others knowing that they have that
option too
at some level be forgiving right and six
and this is as far as i'll read now it's
it's online for those who want to read
more
six hypothesis is a kind of intellectual
property
when one is able to predict things that
are not obvious in advance it suggests
that your model of what is occurring
contains some truth
it is therefore important to track the
sources and fates of predictions for
scientific insight to grow
a hypothesis is yours when it predicts
something novel if it doesn't predict
something new
it may not be different from other
hypotheses
yes this does fit beautifully and so i
would just say that
you know the landscape of hypothesis and
prediction um is a complex one
i mentioned on the campfire with eric
that we had just watched um the big
short with our son
zach and there's a very
uncomfortable period in the middle of
that movie where
you have a number of people who have
figured out that the housing market
is irrational and destined for collapse
and they have bet against it
knowing that that's the the thing to do
in order to profit from
the insight and the
condition remains both
incoherent and stable far longer than it
should have so there's this very nervous
period
the market remains incoherent yes
there's some force playing
against them in which the value of the
assets is not dropping
even though the constituents of these uh
these synthetic bonds made of these
mortgages so the more mortgages have
begun to fail
and people have begun defaulting on
their on their loans
why is the value of these the commodity
not dropping and so anyway this is a
very common thing where
it's just because you're right about
something doesn't mean that it becomes
apparent that you're right
so in this case of this maybe nor does
it necessarily become even if it will
become apparent as in this case you know
we're seeing a movie about it in part
because the entire world ultimately saw
that they were right
but there's almost always an
intermediate period when
um even though there should be dawning
realization either in the data or in the
hearts and minds of people observing the
situation that the
prediction was accurate there is a lag
yeah and during that lag people will
point at you and say aha
see you're wrong and uh there's a famous
quote here
i am a little nervous that i've got the
wrong person and if so it will be deeply
ironic but it may be greenspan
who said something like um the market
can stay
irrational longer than you can stay
solvent so even though you're right
you may end up getting wiped out by your
correct belief because you can't last
long enough to get to the
payoff so all i would say is i'm working
from a model
about what's going on inside the
democratic party that model isn't wrong
just because this prediction turns out
to be wrong which it likely will
that model is right if somewhere
between uh now and the two-year mark of
a biden presidency
he steps down or is forced to step aside
and something else moves into play now
there are ways that that could happen
so just to be clear you're making a few
particular predictions
and obviously what the one prediction
that they will pull him before he
becomes the nominee
is not borne out if he pull if he wins
the election
and pulls out within two years the
broader model
which has several sometimes mutually
incompatible predictions associated with
it
is that he is not a legitimate contender
to the
presidency um yeah so what i would say
is you've got
levels of unlikeliness and obviously the
prediction that i delivered here is the
most unlikely and so
the sort of most aggressive version of
the model will turn out to be wrong if
that prediction isn't right
but the general model that there is
awareness inside the democratic party
that uh biden's purpose is to uh
to put something in office other than
trump but that his purpose is not
governance
and that there is awareness that he uh
does not have the mental capacity left
to function as president um that's the
overarching model
of which i think uh that is not a very
risky
um prediction i find it very hard to
imagine he would go two years and if he
did
it would be the result of the fact that
they figured out some mechanism
for piping stuff into his ear so that
there was no risk of him going off
script but
you know the fact is he can't get
through even a
pro forma introduction to a scripted
talk without
straying too far so it's kind of hard to
imagine that that
there's any mechanism that will do it
yeah
all right uh shall we switch yes
uh do you want to talk about um
[Music]
sunlight being the best disinfectant uh
other aspects of
covid uh or compelled speech first what
do you think
wow um yeah uh maybe
geez maybe let's step into the cove and
stuff let's step into the covered stuff
okay um so
uh that's i let's let's do the sunlight
disinfectant stuff last within covid so
starting with
some code risk factors okay so we know
we've
we have been hearing for months now that
uh
race is a correlate of poor outcomes
uh for covert 19 right that uh that and
i did not pull up
uh these papers but i believe that we
have heard that there is evidence across
uh many domains cross many geographic
domains
that um that people of color
specifically
black people and latino people are more
likely to contract covet and are also
more likely to have worse outcomes when
they do contract it
and there's there's obviously a question
of why that might be
so let's take a step back and find some
some other things that we now understand
to be true
poor air quality is understood
to correlate with
increased contraction and worse outcomes
of kovid
so here is a july 28
2020 intercept article zachary
you can pull up
which finds that um
i cannot find okay you can take it down
love
um quote from the paper quote from the
article that i couldn't find right there
when i pulled it up for you guys
respiratory illnesses are no stranger to
the latino communities who live around
california's largest lake the salton sea
asthma rates here are some of the
highest in california with air quality
routinely failing
to meet federal and state standards
thanks in part the state's omnipresent
water wars
the water in this desolate former
vacation destination is rapidly drying
up
salinating the lake and releasing
decades-old contaminants into the air
so there's a whole lot that we could say
about what the sultan sea is you know it
was originally a desert flat that got
formed by accident when
the colorado river got dumped a bunch of
bunch of water got dumped there
and it became briefly this vacation
destination
but then something about a lot of
another water move
a lot of water being moved to san diego
i think basically began desalinating
or rather salinating the lake by
decreasing the water levels in the lake
so that you have these towns
with names like oasis and mecca where
really no vacationers any longer visit
or or live there
and of course what you have are um a lot
of
of latinos who are often farm workers
sometimes
migrant farm workers often not um who
live there because
housing is cheap because it sucks to
live there right and so what we have
is a finding that latinos living near
the salton sea
have higher rates of covid um and have
worse outcomes when they get covered
um but we what we really have here is a
as a class issue
right that uh you know i predict that
anyone who is living in the salton sea
is going to have these higher rates of
asthma and prolonged respiratory
problems and that when a respiratory
virus shows up
of course they're going to be more
susceptible to it as well
similarly we have high population
density
being a predictor of bad outcomes in
covid so here's
zach you want to put this up just
briefly a fairly
badly dud article in willamette week out
of portland
uh the title being people are more
likely to catch cove at east of 82nd
avenue
that's where portland's housing is the
most overcrowded in this case the
headline is better than the article
because the article actually really
consistently conflates
race and class and and doesn't
doesn't grant that actually both of
those things are correlated with
um overcrowding so except in
high density urban centers where living
in a high rise is actually
sometimes an indicator of wealth we know
that being in overcrowded housing
conditions
is correlated with class and because of
historical
racism maybe modern racism but certainly
due to historical racism which
apparently irritates the cat no end
um as it should it should um we have
uh people who have been um
oppressed in the historically oppressed
populations who are lit who are more
likely to be living in high
population density um housing and so
again
we have you know how how is it that we
can tease apart race and class
we have a result uh that people of color
are more likely to be getting coveted
and suffering worse when they do but is
it true
that that is true even when you control
for class i don't know
i don't know and then finally we have
factory work
factory work uh which of course brings
with both high population density when
you're in factories and low air quality
and
obviously is a correlate for class
here's a story from the guardian on july
11th
oops la basque factories shut down as
hundreds of workers get sick now this
obviously brings in the additional
problem
of now masks aren't being made because
it's mask factories that are being shut
down
but the the point is that we have a
number of these things pointing in the
same direction
right that class um seems to be
a uh a predictor
of uh sorry for those
listening and not watching there's a cat
on the screen on the table now
um class is certainly a predictor
of bad outcomes for kovid uh but is
is race separately from class i'm not
i'm not sure that that's true and i
don't know that it's not true but
um i'm not sure so one more thing brett
before you start commenting as you
extract the cat without knocking over
our water we have a cdc report that came
out
just uh yesterday zach if you would show
this
hospitalization rates and
characteristics of children aged less
than 18 years
hospitalized with laboratory confirmed
covet 19.
um in 14 states from march 1st july 25th
and one of the results of this report
one of the findings
they have they report is that indeed
specifically latino and black children
had higher cumulative
rates of covet associate
hospitalizations uh
and uh and well well that did they that
they had worse outcomes than than white
kids
and this one this report i believe does
not attempt to
tease out whether or not that was true
if you would control for class as well
um i would just point out that there are
ways actually that what we
and i've said elsewhere i won't go into
it here but
the term race is a problem because it's
not
it is a fiction but it is not entirely a
fiction it is a
social fiction built around something
that we might call population or lineage
and um that those things are real
biological phenomena whereas race is
polluted by politics
but in any case there are ways i think
that warrants
saying again i mean this is just
incredibly important population is a
real
concept that yes all populations pretty
much will have fuzzy boundaries both
temporally and spatially but that
doesn't make them
not real whereas race is like the
politicization the
politization is the situation it's the
weaponization
of yeah and maybe it was from the
beginning and maybe it wasn't i'm not i
don't know
um but it is it appears to be a
context-free ideology-free description
of populations but it of course is not
it is not and you can tell that because
um you know a one-drop
rule is obviously a political phenomenon
not a biological phenomenon
yeah but i would there's one fly on the
ointment here which is
what drives people to weaponize it is
a kind of racism to which humans are
prone
yeah and so it is your genes trying to
get you to advance their
interests you know against the values
that
most of us would hold that causes things
like a one-drop rule to emerge and we
can talk about the biological basis for
that
another time but it's a complex story
race is simultaneously
a fiction it is a bastardization of
something biological
it is itself not a biological
description but the
the warping the distortion is driven
by a biological motivation that is not
honorable and
to which we should be responding and um
figuring out how to prevent it from
having hegemony but in any case
i would just point out there's a way
that race can play into this that has
everything to do with actual population
of origin
yes and nothing to do with racism
and i would just say that that has to do
with the fact that vitamin d has
consistently shown up
so we'll get as we're going there okay
well no i mean
all i would say is the simple
interaction
so the reason that some people have dark
skin
is because their ancestors come from a
place where the sun comes in through the
atmosphere
more directly the closer you are to the
equator the more directly the sun comes
through the atmosphere the less of it is
absorbed on the way down
the sun's rays hit the earth more
perpendicularly and so go through less
atmosphere to get to the earth and so it
is it you get
you you you get more of it and for you
standing in any one place get
more of it standing there per hour or
per year or whatever and the point is
uv light as we're about to discuss is
extremely destructive stuff
and so melanin is built-in sunscreen
right
rather than sunscreen that you either
wear or slather on
it is sunscreen that's built into the
skin and of course
people who tan i've never been very good
at it but people who tan
are you know ratcheting up in time their
production of the
this molecule to shield their their
basically feel their dna from the damage
that comes from uv light
but in any case that shield whatever it
is
whether it's a jacket or whether it's
melanin in your skin
interrupts the production of vitamin d
which is photosynthetically created in
our skin
in response to sunlight and so vitamin d
for whatever reason has shown up as a
primary factor you will you are less
likely to get sick
and you are if you do get sick you are
likely to get much less sick
if you have proper levels of vitamin d
rather than are deficient
and so that can interact in just a
physiological way with different
populations the prediction of course
of that being that populations will
suffer in
uh in proportion
to the degree of darkness of their skin
even individuals might be able
you could see this pattern within
individuals darker people um
might be more affected so that would be
a non that has nothing to do with racism
right but it has to do with has to do
with race but not with racism
and then this these findings that seem
to have to very much to do with class
um class correlates with race 100
due to historical racism but is it due
to modern racism
that is actually a hypothesis that needs
to be demonstrated right
and and um and no one appears to be
testing it we are all expected to simply
accept it
well and i would just point out that
this is you know i don't know if we're
going to get to
what two plus two might equal but um the
this is the tragic irony of this
um desire to unhook all of the
structures that we have built and
discovered to evaluate what might be
true
the claim that these things are all
weaponized and therefore none of them
are trustworthy as preposterous what you
want in this circumstance
is something called an anova you want an
analysis that tells you what
fraction of the difference in
susceptibility to covid or the degree of
symptoms that you have
is due to class what if you control for
class what fraction of it is due to race
if you control for those things what
fraction of it is due to
the darkness of your skin what fraction
of it is due to zip code
so the point is all of these things have
a contribution
that can be discovered you can't do it
perfectly but we have the tools the
bigger the sample
the better the tools work and we can
figure out how much of these things
are due to x y z factor
and ultimately there will be a factor
that has to do with modern racism is a
big
factor small factor we can predict but
should we be trying to reduce modern
racism to zero of course of course
right all right all right um
so um i can move into the the sunlight
and uv thing now unless you had other
things you want to talk about with
regard to cove at first
um no we can we can come back to them
all right
all right so um a super chat question
that we got
in episode 36 that we did not get to
pointed to
this article zach if you want to put
this up
so i think i think the person who asked
who pointed us to this this is a 2020
article from
june far uvc light 222 nanometers
efficiently and safely inactivates
airborne human coronaviruses
so give me my screen back if you will
zach thank you
um i quote from the abstract uh that
uh far ubc light and the 207 to 222
nanometer
range efficiently kills pathogens
potentially without harm
potentially without harm to exposed
human tissues
so the authors here have tested against
two coronaviruses although not sars cove
too
yet and found high efficacy against
those coronaviruses as well as in
previous work against influenza
so they basically had already they were
already primed and ready to look and see
if this far
uv light would be um deactivating
viruses because they had previously done
this work to test whether it would be
against influenza and so in
in both of the papers that um that i've
found
that they that they are talking about
here um they find that it is
so wait a question yeah um the structure
of this claim
that this particular wavelength of uv
light
um destroys the pathogen without damage
to tissue
they're not talking about using this
light
in or on the tissue but the question is
about using the light
um as a disinfectant in an environment
and that a person in that environment
would be unharmed so
whereas some wavelengths of light you
could potentially cause skin cancers for
example if you had
enough of it um in this case what
they're saying
and we've actually talked about this
right i argued in one
prior live stream that um that we could
envision
light bulbs that would disinfect a room
when nobody was present
and that's what that's the super chat
question was in response to that
and this is exactly what these guys are
are saying we should be doing but
they're also
apparently saying you don't have to have
light bulbs that know when you're in the
room and disinfect when you're not
that you could disinfect a room without
hurting the people in it
using this particular wave so in fact
actually the where
uh what i'm looking at right now they
say the most commonly employed type of
uv light for germicidal applications is
a low pressure mercury vapor arc lamp
and we're
emitting around 254 nanometers more
recently xenon lamp technology has been
used which emits broad uv spectrum
however while these lamps can be used to
disinfect unoccupied spaces
direct exposure to conventional
germicidal uv lamps in occupied public
spaces is not possible
because direct exposure to these
germicidal lamp wavelengths can be a
health hazard both to the skin and eye
by contrast
um we see we there is no evidence yet
um that in the range they are finding
efficacy against coronaviruses in the
207 to 222 nanometer range
that they are uh damaging to human
tissue so
they they may well have found the sweet
spot here and that's you know that's
that's amazing so um i have a bunch more
to say here but you want to
comment um i want to add one thing yeah
that lots of stuff
where we have a legacy device like our
lights
could be upgraded for this purpose
there's another place where i see this
opportunity
we have hvac systems
that recirculate air and they do it for
a good reason which is that
you know if you took outside air for
example then in the winter
you would have to heat it up from a very
low temperature rather than taking air
which is cooled in a room reheating it
you're eating it a
very small amount so efficiency wise
this is important
there are however times when you might
um adjust your hvac system so that it
was circulating air the way
your car system circulates air
so that yeah well i mean in a car we're
all familiar with you can choose whether
or not you're breaking in outside air or
recirculating
exactly but my point is there are times
i'm not a huge fan of air conditioning i
happen to think it creates a
huge amount of ill health but
if you're not cooling air or heating it
you might still want to use the system
to circulate outside
air in and if you had a net flow through
it would decrease the chances of
at least contracting covet would it work
generally with flu and other pathogens
maybe but in this case wouldn't it be
great if you could get your hvac system
to work for you rather than against you
right yeah or early i don't remember
when but one of the first live streams
that we did
um i was talking about the results uh
that in fact you know opening windows is
more effective
than running running your hvac but it
may be that there's a way to
uh to to fix the hvac system such that
they could be effective in the same way
that
um that opening windows is effective
as basically an anti-viral agent and
lessening the uh
the bad symptoms of the disease and
indeed i think if if memory serves
during tuberculosis tuberculosis
outbreaks around world war one maybe
uh that basically taking patients who
were infected outside
uh increased their survival rates
significantly just getting them outside
where
there was air flow and where there was
sunlight yeah it'd be interesting enough
um
vitamin d was a contributor there too
yeah um i would just as a final piece
there
it is certainly already possible and we
could greatly enhance the capacity of
hvac systems even when you're
recirculating air within a building
to physically filter out things like
particles which is costly energetically
speaking
but also to use uv light exactly to
disinfect this stuff so
all of these systems could be could
become wise about
absolute infection yeah and and they
should be yeah
absolutely so um i guess one place i
wanted to go with regard to this
research um is it's an opportunity for
us once again
to talk about the risk of hyper novelty
right uh and the
and also to talk about the value of the
precautionary principle when we modify
our ancestral conditions
so i was asked at a conference last
summer i don't think i told you about
this interaction
by this rich young woman who was rather
self-satisfied in the way that rich
people sometimes
are what value spending time in nature
could possibly have
she had heard me talking about it and
she was affronted by the
the very thought that spending time in
nature
um would have value and she said to me i
don't know if this is a direct quote but
something like why aren't the things we
learn on screens a complete replacement
i made the mistake of generating a list
for her on the spot and i said things
like well you know we know that stress
hormones are lowered when we're in
nature
and that physical movement that's
required at least to get to nature and
often when you're in nature
is well understood to be healthy across
a number of anatomical and physiological
systems
and the value of facing an environment
that is not human-made
and so can throw you curveballs um
that you have no way of either fully
predicting or of negotiating with is
huge
that is to say and this is a point that
we make in the book that we're writing
and have made many
times before but there's no arguing your
way out of a storm front
or a river that has risen three feet
since the last time you crossed it
or the setting sun you can't watch light
levels descend
and make a social negotiation with the
descending light levels
unless you're inside right unless you're
inside but you're the physical world
is this non-arbitrary arbitrator
of do you actually have a model of your
universe that makes some sense
and um and so you know i said all that
to her and she was you know mostly not
convinced
because she was not prepared to be
convinced uh but i actually
realized right in the aftermath and
again thinking about this
research that the better answer is this
the better answer is we don't know
all of the benefits of spending time
outdoors we have some of them and here's
this list right
and there are many more that we do know
but we do know that we have done so for
almost all of our existence and that as
we've been spending less time outdoors
our health has begun to fail us and that
suggests that there is value there even
if we cannot yet point to what all of
the value is or what the benefits are
i'm grateful that there are people who
are discerning what some of those
benefits are and that we have discerned
some of them and are talking about them
but i'm also certain that there are more
and it's not incumbent on me
defending the ancestral condition to
come up with the benefits of it to
defend
it it's incumbent upon the new thing to
defend
why it can't possibly be getting in the
way
so this is this is chesterton's fence
also right when you come upon a fence
and it's in your way if you want to
destroy it
chesterton uh would would say you have
to tell me what the fence is there for
and if you cannot tell me what it's
there for i don't want you getting rid
of it because you clearly don't know its
value if you could tell me what it's
there for could then make an argument
for its removal
maybe we can talk about removing it but
until and unless
you can accurately and completely
describe what the thing is
do not get rid of it and you know we in
our last
super chat q a we fielded a question
about the appendix and it's the same
thing
don't get rid of the appendix until you
have a really good sense of what it's
there for we actually now
after a hundred years of people getting
rid of their appendices i don't know if
that's how you pluralize the organ or
not
i certainly do whether it's accurate
right um
are now coming to an understanding of
what what it's there for
so the default assumption should be
that it is it is not actually helpful to
do the thing
that since we've started doing it has
been associated with decreasing
health right um
i guess one more one more thing on this
if you want to jump unless you want to
jump in right here well i just want to
say
you know the problem is we
are too in love with our analytical
abilities which
indeed do make us special as creatures
sure do
um but there is a sense in which
um you can you have an intuition that
being outside is healthy virtually
everyone has this intuition
that's right um and it is likely to be
based on
something significant i mean just i
would point to one example
that if you are kitty cat if you
are backpacking and you are suddenly
exposed to a normal
light regime you are liable to find
yourself not
so eager to stay up into the wee hours
and not so eager to stay in bed
after the sun has come up but um
it just simply reinforces a
normal relationship to day and night and
this sets in so
quickly that a discovery that yeah you
know we have all of these
you know i'm particularly i'm very
interested in
tracing down all of the little things
that you can discover in your life that
actually do you harm
you know hence the discovery that i'm
massively allergic to wheat which is
really hard to detect because it's in
everything
but um you know the idea that blue
lights cause it to be
very difficult to go back to sleep and
you know yellow lights
don't these sorts of things are patterns
you can detect in your own life
and we all have sleep issues because we
are constantly flooded by all kinds of
arbitrary nonsense
and the fact that all you have to do
even if you can't specify what it is
that you've
eliminated is going into environment
where
you know there are very few um novel
influences and you're restored to just a
slate of ancestrally
representative ones and it fixes your
problem most most viewers will
have heard of the the fad but the you
know legitimate and its base fad for
elimination diets right that you take
out
you take out all the things that you
think might be causing you whatever
problems that you're having
and you reintroduce them slowly one by
one well backpacking is maybe a kind of
environmental elimination diet
no it's an illumination diet where you
change the wavelengths that you were
encountering
and it's an environmental elimination
diet that actually takes out all of the
novel things of modern life
with the exception of what you have
brought with you and you can see if you
get healthy i mean the pun is cute but
it actually really um
really diminishes the point sorry about
that as puns do often disrespect
um no but i mean i think this is this is
important i was you know really i was
reframing what i heard you say that this
is this is a kind of
environmental elimination diet that has
a great value
and that's you know that's an that's
that's a kind of hybrid answer between
the listing that i gave this woman of
what the benefits
are of of being in nature and what i
thought
later the more apt answer was you just
don't know
and because the change has been
correlated with a decrease in health you
should assume that it's better
but but but that this allows you to
actually find out which of the things
that you're doing
um might be unhealthy or just oh i went
and spent a week
out away from all of the usual
toxins and influences and screens and
all of this and
these five things i didn't even know
were correlated went away
okay i still don't know what all that
i'm doing in my normal life that's
associated with
but i could be pretty sure that it was
something that wasn't out there when i
was backpacking
right so um
we have another this is another benefit
of being outdoors right sunlight
is literally disinfectant it's literally
disinfectant and
i think our grandmothers knew this at
some level although i don't know if
grandmother's particularly said it but
just a side note on that we've probably
all heard this you know sunlight is the
best disinfectant but
we know when we hear that that it's
usually invoked metaphorically
and so here we have this perfect
convergence of literal and metaphorical
truths
which is not always the case that this
sunlight is the best disinfectant
it's not sunlight is not going to be
literally the best disinfectant in all
cases but
uh in in the case of many germs it is
and sunlight is the best disinfectant is
a metaphorical truth as well and so i
just i went down
this little tiny little historical road
that i found interesting so i thought
i'd share with
with you and and all of you today
um this was used first well this was
used as a metaphor by lewis brandeis who
is a supreme court justice from 1916 to
1939
in his 1914 essay called what publicity
can do
which itself was in his book again a
1914 book called other people's money
and how the bankers use it
so the complete quotation i mean it's
still a brief quotation but from
brandeis is
publicity is justly commended as a
remedy for social and industrial
diseases
sunlight is said to be the best of
disinfectants electric light
the most efficient policeman
so we never hear that second part no we
never hear it and yet i think that
there's something
there's something truly deep there
around combining
the sort of post-industrial landscape
and the benefits
and the virtues of it that we are also
dependent on
but not presuming that it can fully
replace and not wanting for it to fully
replace the things
that the pre-industrial landscape offers
us as well
finally one more note on this uh
brandeis himself um
didn't actually come up with this uh so
uh it's a quote from an 1888 book by
james bryce
zack if you want to put this up here and
i'll just um read
read this uh public opinion is a sort of
atmosphere
fresh keen and full of sunlight like
that of the american cities
and the sunlight kills many of those
noxious germs which are hatched where
politicians congregate
maybe that for now we'll stop there cool
now um i would just point out that in
the
case of kovid we find both the
metaphorical and literal
in play beyond sunlight being the best
disinfectant no no
i mean sunlight being the best
disinfectant because the
the literal use here that there is
actually this um
you know uv light disinfects especially
with respect to covet
for now it's not to say it couldn't
evolve a protection and
this goes to the second part which is
the complete lack of transparency
surrounding what took place in china and
allowed this
um virus to escape china which it
certainly
did as a result of bad information and
whether it possibly escaped
from a lab where it had been enhanced
for the purpose of
research the lack of transparency there
is making this a much more dangerous
pandemic
there are lots of features as we keep
saying here and it's getting no traction
in the world but
the possibility that this virus was
trained to do what it does in serial
passage experiments where it was
selected artificially by putting it into
either tissues or creatures or both and
training it to infect for the purpose of
studying it
the question really is what if that is
what happened
what were the exact conditions of those
experiments
because from that list of exact
conditions we can expect
places where it was drawn into one kind
of structure
and it will evolve back in the other
direction over time
we may even be seeing this initially
this virus had a very hard time
infecting children
we are now seeing significant damage to
children
that could be the result of the fact
that we are now detecting a pattern that
was there all along and we didn't see it
or it could be the fact that it is
evolving and it is losing the
characteristics that were favored in a
laboratory environment
and taking on these other
characteristics so
this is not an academic question this is
a practical medical question
and we have no transparency right right
we still have this is what journalism
and the courts are for
and uh we we seem to be lacking
we seem to be getting a highly
politicized push across basically every
every aspect of the kobe 19 story right
and the fact is are
our governments should come together
over this the point is no matter who is
at fault and in what way for this having
happened we are all in the same boat
with respect to figuring out
what this virus is and how we can
control it because it could be with us
for a very long time
and uh it turns out that it
is even if it is less lethal than we
once thought
and we've been talking about this for
weeks it is not
as deadly as we feared it is however
apparently much more destructive people
who recover
are not fully recovered and so zach
could you put up
um the first of those articles that i
sent you
so here we have an article
about damage to the brain a large
percentage of coronavirus
patients 55 have neurological problems
three months later
so this article points to some of the
original research that is illustrating
that there are actually
this is very frightening for it to be in
the brain
and you know there were hints of this
from the beginning the loss of
uh the system's taste and smell for
example but that we are seeing patterns
where most people who are getting
coronavirus are having
neurological symptoms even months later
even after they've completely
as far as we know cleared the virus
which may mean that they didn't
completely clear it or it may mean that
the damage done by the virus in the
short period of time that they were sick
is having these long lasting
implications and we don't know how long
they last
yeah just um there's an analogy there
between
as we've talked about before the sort of
organizational versus activation effects
of hormones that the virus might have
caused damage in an organizational sort
of way
back then and such that even if your
body has cleared it
you never go back to normal just like
being masculinized with testosterone
as uh as a boy an early teenager you
will never go back to not having been
masculinized by testosterone
whereas an activational effect of a
hormone requires that the trigger be on
for the for the switch to flip and um we
don't know and
in this case it would be is there still
virus present
which is causing the lingering brain
malfunction in which case we need to
clear
the the problem is a little bit simpler
in that case right and it's less dire
in terms of the future for people who've
been infected because well we just need
to clear your body of this thing and
know we don't know how to do it yet but
once once done it's it's good and over
as opposed to if it's more like an
organizational effect wow well you've
got damage and you're going to have
damage
and now we need to figure out how to
mitigate that damage but the damage is
done
yeah but the problem is if it's hiding
out in neurological tissue
there may be no way of getting rid of it
oh so i mean so in another level so like
another analogy with
uh like falcipro malaria or no 5x
malaria that'll hide out in your liver
so that there's no
there's no doing anything with it you
don't feel particularly sick if you're
infected with vivex malaria
but it you also there's no way for
medicine um like chloroquine
to go after it there's no way for normal
medicines there are medicines that will
chase it out of your liver in that case
but there
are viruses herpes viruses for example
hide in neurological tissue
and they effectively retreat to places
that the immune system can't get to them
and
so um anyway this is part of why
for example chickenpox turns into
shingles later in life
right um so anyway if it's if it's
hiding out in neurological tissue that
is
um uh insulated from the immune system
that's very bad news
it's much more incentive for us to
figure out how not to get this thing
rather than
the what was passed for sophistication
early in this thing which was
um if you get it and you have a mild
case you're lucky because you might have
immunity
and you're done right and the answer is
well we don't know if you're done
yeah you know we don't know if you have
immunity
and we do know that there's a very large
chance that you will have had
damage to a major system can you put up
the other articles zach
so i'm going to show you another article
here again this is not the primary
literature this one talks about a number
of different
systems and types of damage can you
scroll down a little bit
but anyway this one talks a bit about
the brain fog that people experience but
also
the heart damage and so we are seeing a
large percentage of people
who have had mild cases where we can
actually see the damage to their hearts
so this is just
a you know yes it's less deadly than you
thought
yes it's more destructive than you
thought you have to adjust your model
accordingly and we
you know there's still all the stuff
that's up in the air about you know if
you get better
and you don't have these symptoms are
you really done will it come back
later will you contract it again in a
year we don't know
right so uh one last topic before we
sign off for the hour and take your
super chat questions in the next hour
um totally totally different topic at
some level
we have been talking for weeks now
months i guess
about the the ideology
that is taking over and making it
difficult for people to say things other
than what is becoming the dominant
the dominant accepted truth on the
street um i've i've been talking about
the don't hurt me walls
and i read from uh hovel's uh
essay on power of the powerlessness
i can't remember exactly what it was
called do with power his green grocer
example
and i've been reading of late this book
called nothing to envy
ordinary lives in north korea by barbara
demick
which she's a journalist now i think the
bureau chief in beijing for the la times
uh who spent a lot of time in south
korea and made several visits to north
korea
talking um talking to people most of the
people she talked to
were were people who had escaped from
north korea and were now in south korea
and told her their personal stories
and one of the things that emerges from
this book
is just a reminder of the risk of
compelled speech and
its utility uh for us
in seeing what yeah at the point that we
are the people are not
feeling free to talk that they are
reporting that they feel self-censorship
or that they have to put a black lives
matter sign up in their window lest
lest the activists come for them we
should be taking that as an indicator of
worse things to come
that compelled speech is a kind of
canary in a coal mine and these signs
and windows are a form of compelled
speech i'm arguing
so let's just um let me just do a very
quick uh
review of what korea is and then read a
couple of short excerpts from this book
so the korean peninsula makes good
geographic sense i should have pulled up
a map i don't have one um
but it's bounded by the sea of japan to
the east and the yellow sea to the west
and a couple of rivers
uh the yalu and the tumen apparently
probably mispronouncing those
at the land boundary with china to the
north um
but it's being split along the 38th
parallel
after world war ii was an arbitrary
little political decision
um arbitrary in terms of where it was um
the
the end of world war ii meant that there
were two major forces in the world
and uh each of them were claiming some
some primacy over korea and that wasn't
going to work and so they knew they were
battling for it um but you know really
to the degree that there was a sort of
natural
cultural or linguistic or tribal or
anything like that split it would have
been
along um you know east and west that
basically people to the east
were more likely gravitating japan and
people to the west to china and there
could have been
a divide that way but the but the split
being put where it was
effectively just cut a um not
homogeneous but
more homogeneous than many population in
two
and people in south ended up with uh
something like a democracy and the
people
in the north ended up with what is
probably the most totalitarian state
in the world today not at the time you
know it took it took some time to get
there
so kim il-sung who ruled north korea
from its founding in 1948 until his
death in 1994
um uh then
after when when he died his son kim
jong-il became head of state when he
died when kim il-sung died in 1994
the entire country became convulsed in
grief and public displays of grief
and those two things grief and public
displays of grief
or public displays of something that
appeared to be grief
were impossible to distinguish between
and that is the point of
what i'm going to read from today so
this is again nothing to envy
ordinary lives in north korea this is
journalistic and
personal story driven accounting of life
in north korea so
pages 98.99 find them here
we have this is in the wake of the death
of kim il-sung the first uh head of
state in north korea
as a 21 year old university student
junson was naturally skeptical of all
authority
including the north korean government he
prided himself on his questioning
intellect
but he didn't think of himself as
seditious or in any way an enemy of the
state
he believed in communism or at least
believed that whatever its faults it was
a more equitable and humane system than
capitalism
he had imagined he would eventually join
the workers party and dedicate his life
to the betterment of the fatherland
that was what was expected of all those
who graduated from the top universities
now surrounded by sobbing students
junsong wondered
if everybody else felt such genuine love
for kim il-sung and he did not
how would he possibly fit in he had been
contemplating his own reaction or lack
thereof with an intellectual detachment
but suddenly he was gripped with fear
he was alone completely alone in his
indifference
he always thought he had close friends
at the university but now he realized he
didn't know them at all
and certainly they didn't know him if
they did he would be in trouble
this revelation was quickly followed by
another equally momentous
his entire future depended on his
ability to cry
not just his career and his membership
in the workers party his very survival
was at stake
it was a matter of life and death jon
song was
terrified at first he kept his head down
so nobody could see his eyes
then he figured out that to be kev's
eyes open long enough they would burn
and tear up
it was like a staring contest stare cry
stare cry eventually it became
mechanical
the body took over where the mind left
off and suddenly he was really crying
he felt himself falling to his knees
rocking back and forth
sobbing just like everyone else nobody
would be the wiser
and one more unless you want to comment
on that one uh
seems to speak for itself yeah
exactly um a short shorter excerpt here
from
page 101 of this book what had started
as a spontaneous outpouring of grief
became a patriotic
obligation women weren't supposed to
wear makeup or do their hair during a
10-day morning period
drinking dancing and music were banned
the
inman ban kept track of how often people
went to the statue to show their respect
everybody was being watched they not
only scrutinized actions but facial
expressions and tone of voice
gauging them for sincerity miran had to
go twice a day for the 10 day morning
period once with the children from the
kindergarten and once just with her work
unit of teachers
she began to dread it not just the grief
but the responsibility of making sure
the fragile children didn't get trampled
or worked themselves into hysteria
there was one five-year-old girl in her
class who cried so loudly and was so
demonstrative in her grief
grief that miran worried she would
collapse
but then she noticed the girl was
spitting in her hand to dampen her face
with saliva
there were no actual tears my mother
told me if i don't cry i'm a bad person
the girl confessed
wow so
north korea is unique we're not north
korea
it is a particularly remarkable
and extreme authoritarian totalitarian
communist state but
the tactics that are used to
get people to fall in line to get them
to comply
to cause them to act out of fear
and some people who act out of fear will
at some point begin to believe
the things that they say out of fear
just out of self-preservation
are familiar at this point i would say
that they're familiar to us
increasingly these tactics yeah not the
outcome
we are seeing instinct to it
right the degree to which we are
compelled varies based on where you are
what industry you're in and all of this
but we are seeing the
instinct to compel people to feel even a
particular way about things okay
we are seeing a rejection of the idea
that you are free to formulate your own
opinion about this that or the other and
here's i mean i do think there's a deep
philosophical question here which i feel
i know the answer to but
i cannot defend it the question is
are we justified um certainly almost
everybody who
will be listening to this podcast will
agree
that there is something marvelous about
being
free now i think we have to think
carefully about what being free
is because it's very easy to take
freedom and treat it frivolously
basically to squander freedom and should
we be entitled to
my guess is we should be that that's
part of freedom but
um at some level the ability
to figure out how in what to invest your
freedom
right and the values that will cause you
to invest it in some invested in
something good
rather than to waste it those things to
me seem
simply superior to a system
that sustains life it may even do some
things
better than a system in which you are
free because freedom involves freedom to
fail
whereas a system that drives freedom out
may be able to guarantee that at least
that doesn't happen to you but
but in any case we are facing a question
about whether or not you know by what
standard is
the success of a system to be measured
are we to be simply horrified by a
system that compels you to cry in order
to
advertise your um complete mental
alignment with your population
even if that provides some kind of
stability i think so
but but i mean also i guess i would say
the question that you ask is are we to
be simply horrified as opposed to
perhaps the implied alternative was
finding something good there
but one alternative implied alternative
that i heard was
or can we learn from it can we learn
from it even though
uh the outcome is not an outcome that um
any reasonable person would want can we
learn from
the tactics that we saw on the ground
there and say
perhaps perhaps these are indicators of
a authoritarian movement that's afoot
well i agree that they are i mean and
nobody who listens to us is going to be
shocked that we both
find the authoritarian of the
authoritarian-ness of this movement
the most telling and frightening
hallmark of it
but i think i'm asking something deeper
which is that effectively
you have a movement that is availing
itself of you're talking about in the us
in the u.s a movement that is availing
itself of the ability
to pressure every institution into
saying
false things absurd things demanding
things and
we could draw a line where it violates
the law which it does sometimes
but there's an awful lot that it does
through scaring people
below a level where it's illegal to do
so and so on what basis
do we claim actually we have the right
to halt this process
if the process itself does not
inherently violate
the um at least the constraints that we
lay out
at the level of um of
legal limits and i believe fully that we
have the right to shut this movement
down because it is a threat
you know we could make the argument and
we have made the argument it is a threat
to the stability of our system
so to the extent that the purpose of our
system is to
provide for people if this in the end
results in its inability to do that
that's one basis on which you might
object to it
but there's also something objectionable
about the very fact
that it does not value freedom right and
you know i'm not one of these people as
you well know
i'm not one of these people who thinks
that absolute
freedom that the ability to do anything
is great i think that the constraints
that actually
liberate you meaningfully are extremely
useful and actually i think that the
ridiculous discussion we've been having
about basic arithmetic is exactly this
question
and the point is you become freer
when math does not allow you to choose
what the plus symbol means
if we agree on what the plus symbol
means that is a reduction in some narrow
kind of freedom that
buys you the ability to make an airplane
to go somewhere it buys you the ability
to have a negotiation with other people
and know what it means to enforce an
agreement
these things are liberating and so the
constraint liberates it's like the fd
a rules allow you to eat and not fear
you're going to be poisoned the faa
rules allow you to get on an airplane
and fly to wherever so constrains the
fba is doing a better job in the fda
well the whole thing is coming apart so
at some level i don't know which acronym
is going to be the last acronym standing
but um
i guess they're not acronyms they're uh
whatever they are
but but the question is can
must we be horrified on the basis that
they are building a system
or threatening to build a system that
will rob us all of the ability to live
or can we be horrified on the basis
that um they don't honor freedom and
that we know that actually there's just
simply something
better about any ideology that aspires
to liberate people in a meaningful sense
is actually simply better than any
ideology that discounts freedom as an
important value
yeah yeah that's good uh and maybe
that's the place to stop
all right on that note i will remind you
the nominations um
for unity 2020 are now open you should
go to
articles of unity.org
nominate nominate up to two people and
um
then we will quickly get in this
upcoming week to a debate on who we
would like to see
elected which i think is going to be
very interesting excellent
and we will be answering your questions
uh as many as we can get to from this
hour
and next hour that you deliver via super
chat
uh starting in about 15 minutes at a
link that will be in the description
below this video
you can find a discord server as a
benefit at both of our patreon
patreons and also get access to a
private monthly q a that we do in the
last sunday of every month at my patreon
and that's it for now i guess yep
monthly discussions
uh at my patreon last year were great
lots of new faces plenty of
folks who've been around in those
discussions for a while they've been
very lively and
i think everybody seems to enjoy them so
um consider that
yeah next hour even more catfell all
right see you shortly
[Music]
you